stafford is with us in charleston south
carolina
hi stafford how are you hey doing great
dave i appreciate you taking my call
sure how can we help um yeah so
me and my fiance are getting married in
july which we're very excited about
since thank you since i was a kid my
parents followed your plan and passed
all those values to me and so
i appreciate that um because i've been
debt-free since you know out of school
and
um been really just trying to stay on
that one my life goals is to be consumer
debt-free
great um and so we're getting married
but she's got some credit card debt
and some student loans and so it's not a
matter of if to pay off the credit
cards and the student loans but how to
go about doing it
um and so we've got some cash saved up
that we have to pay for the wedding
um as well as we want to do some home
renovations um
but the question was is it worth trying
to settle on some of this credit card
debt
by calling and and settle in directly
with the credit cards
uh she's not behind she needs her
minimum payment but she don't know she
doesn't make enough though
no they won't they're not going to
settle if you're not behind they're not
going to settle
the only reason they settle is if you're
in default and they and you're gonna
have to screw up her credit to do that
so women i'm sorry i drove right by
something you're gonna pay for the
wedding how much money you have
i've got about 50 000 in savings right
now
and how much you spend on the wedding
uh we're paying a portion of it so we're
probably putting 15
towards the wedding which leaves 35 and
she has 37.
right so when you come home from the
honeymoon you write a check and pay off
the debt
no no no home renovations i heard you
sneak that through there
he did he just and then just to go just
drive by
she's starting to push the wedding back
unless you get some stuff
knocked out so i'm a single guy living
at a house for about myself for a while
and stuff
yeah well i mean we're not talking about
putting it off for very long you're
going to have zero debt
and you're going to be on a budget
together and you have your emergency
fund in place you'll be able to save up
for home renovations as your next
goal gotcha so you're saying don't try
to
negotiate just try to just pay it off
and move on
well you're they're not going to
negotiate does she want to pay off this
debt
yes okay because this is a this is a we
need to be on the same page with values
and how we handle money
in addition to paying off the debt
because if you pay off the debt and
she's still excited about using credit
cards there's you gotta run into this
problem again
no absolutely she's ready to get rid of
it she just she works for a ministry and
isn't making enough deb okay get above
those so what do you make payments so
i make a hundred a year what about 500 a
week in a
title so she's doing about 28 a year
okay all right and what's the how much
in
whose home is renovating who are we
moving who's your house her house what
it's my house and what does it need how
much you need to spend on it
uh probably about 30 000. okay
all right and so with a hundred and
something thousand dollar household
income and no debt
in the world and you knowing how to do
it be on a budget and her learning how
to be on a budget
and we both have one goal and that's do
some of these renovations you probably
can do them in a few stages
you could start almost immediately on
the first stage
right and debt-free then you're you're
making those renovations debt-free
yeah i don't think the credit card
company is going to settle with you when
you're not behind
i got you and i don't think anybody else
is either and i wouldn't recommend you
put her behind
merely for the purposes of settling um
but i think it's real important that the
two of you lay out a detailed
see all i'm doing is i'm not saying
don't do something
i'm saying doing it in a very specific
order
that gives you the least that gives you
the most
money and the least risk
right that's why that's the thing is
yeah because i think we're on the same
page in terms of
is wanting to get rid of it it's not in
i
it's a good thing i don't know about
credit card settlement i guess it's a
good thing that i don't know that but
yeah i just was doing information
reading
well you're trying to get everything
done at once by paying less for the debt
so that you can go ahead and start the
home renovations
which is not a bad question to ask it's
a reasonable question to ask but
here's the thing the reason anyone like
think about if someone owes you money
the only reason you would take less than
what was owed is because you don't think
you're gonna get your money
and you don't think you're gonna get
your money because they haven't been
paying
and so when you you know a lot of these
companies that that for instance they
call themselves debt consolidation
companies they're not all they do is put
you on a payment plan where you start
paying them
instead of credit card companies the
credit cards get behind and then they
settle on
after they've destroyed your credit and
put you into default
and so i wouldn't set out to destroy i
don't set out to build credit but i
wouldn't set out to destroy it either
not when you have the ability to pay a
bill that is legitimate
i would just pay the bill and then i do
my home repairs as my second order of
business
which by the way your home repairs are
probably all going to be done within 12
months
and a whole bunch of them are going to
be done by christmas yeah it's not never
it's just not right now
it's in this specific order yeah and
that that's a
there's a reason for that so kristy i've
done that
exercise a bazillion times with people
that i'm coaching
on the air here or otherwise but sharon
and i had to do it you know i mean
she's driving one of these ugly blue
thousand years ago
two-tone blue astro van you remember
those yes
nasty nasty butt little van it was
completely worn out
i mean there was stuff growing in the
thing we had raised children
animals were making homes yeah we raised
children in this van and she's like
we and we you know we're the business
was starting to grow and we had a little
bit of money
and she's like we need to get a suburban
and i'm like
no i've got this thing at the office we
need to do this thing at the business
you know and
and we got in this big argument yeah are
we gonna do this thing at the business
first are we gonna invest in the
business are we gonna buy stupid
suburban
and you know because i i'm like no i
mean we're gonna grow the business
there's no question no we're getting a
suburban there's no question
and finally between the two of us were
stupid but we finally figured it out
we could do both yeah it was only a
matter of which one went first
and guess what went first we started
with a suburban and then
the next batch of money you know that
came through we used to grow the stuff
at the office here yeah
and uh but you know it's not no it's
just which is first yeah
it's not like no you can't do the stuff
the business no you're never gonna get a
suburban
you just have to decide the proper or
it's not like no we're not going to do
renovations or no we're not going to pay
off the debt
right it's just a matter of the laying
out that order and that order
indicates what you value and that's why
you asked that question about what
what our values are yeah and i think
also whenever you're seeing two people
come together
they're getting married they're so
excited one has had brought debt into
the marriage one has been financially
responsible has no debt
you've got to have some of these
conversations because habits have to
change
it's it's fine you know it's fine if you
didn't have it all together before you
got married
but you need to get on the same page so
that as a married couple
you're making those decisions together
about debt about savings about where and
how you spend and sometimes you have to
wrestle it out like that example matt
and i've had
plenty of those conversations of which
comes first and which is more important
and everybody speaks into it
but the only that's why i wanted to ask
that cause i thought okay if this is the
past that's totally fine
we'll make sure it's not going to be the
future spending habits whenever you're
talking about credit cards that time we
get into we have to get in lockstep
uh especially a newlywed couple because
you're gonna it's the number one thing
couples fight about
and it's one of the data points we find
with the millionaires
is that they not always but
the vast majority of them i forget the
number
their spouses were on board with them
they were working together they weren't
one of them pulling the other one along
yeah
yeah and uh and they were you know two
adults
making decisions about their future and
he's gonna have a lot better time and
she is as well making those home
renovations being debt-free it's gonna
be a lot more fun to pick stuff out and
make decisions
yeah not with credit card debt hovering
over your shoulder yeah that's a good
point